Kate Hudson reveals the best love advice
she's received from her mom Goldie Hawn
18 you heard it here first
what's the best piece of advice your
mom's given you in terms of love advice
she has her stuff with my dad and we
talk about that too you know I mean I
think what they have in terms of
connection is really rare and beautiful
but it doesn't come without its it's
it's tough as well advice is I think be
true to yourself when you're connected
intimately it's a huge time of growth
yeah so it's just sort of accept what
that is and to go there even when it's
uncomfortable the actress was in New
York on Tuesday promoting her new book
pretty happy they wish you say this
point in your life you do feel pretty
happy and how did you get to that pretty
obvious it's a holistic approach to how
to stay healthy without sort of this
pressure that I think a lot of times we
feel you know you have to eat raw
totally totally you know you have to
work out like you know six days a week I
think that it's daunting for a lot of
too much pressure
Kate's happiness radiates on the inside
and out from photo shoots to lounging on
her couch to this cheeky big girl looks
good on the saucy pan that was my
stylist that was Sophie okay okay she
was celebrating my tissue that's what
she does ode to the tertian ode to all
kinds of tissues